التقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان مع نظيره الايراني حسين امير عبد
اللهيان على هامش الاجتماع الوزاري
لاصدقائي مجموعه بريكس بمدينه كيب تاون في
جنوب افريقيا واوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه في
بيان انه جرى خلال اللقاء بحث سبل تعزيز
العلاقات الثنائيه في العديد من المجالات
بالاضافه الى متابعه خطوات تنفيذ اتفاق
البلدين
الموقعي في بكين بما فيه تكثيف العمل
الثنائي لضمان تحقيق الامن والسلم
الدوليين وعبر الجانبان خلال اللقاء عن
تطلعهما الى تكثيف اللقاءات التشاوريه
وبحث سبل التعاون لتحقيق المزيد من الافاق
الايجابيه للعلاقات الثنائيه والمتعدده
الاطراف بما يخدم مصالح البلدين والشعبين
انضم الى هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب الصحفي
جاسر جاسر حياك الله
من الرياض لقاء جديد بين الوزيرين السعودي
والايراني ما الذي يمكن قراءته في تسريع
وتيره هذا
الاتفاق بين البلدين وتنفيذ ما اتفق عليه
من الطرفين
اعتقد انه واضح المسار يعني يمكن لو طرحنا
الاسئله في عشره مارس ايام اتوقع الاتفاق
كان في هناك اسئله قلقه بشكل كبير اليوم
لا نتحدث عن خطوات عمليه خزال القلق
درجه تفاؤل ارتفعت بشكل كبير على التفاصيل
يعني موضوع السفارات انتهت في الاجراءات
التنفيذيه لم يعد هناك مشكله عيون السفراء
تم يعني فدخلنا فيه المرحله حتى في الاطار
الزمني المتفق عليه ولعل في نقاط مهمه
كثره اللقاءات بين الامير فيصل والوزير
الخارجيه الايراني بشكل متكرر وفي كل
المناسبات المختلفه
الايرانيه المتواليه يعني بشكل يوم
تصريحات عن تطور لا ننسى ايضا اللقاء
الاقتصادي في بنك الاسره في اجتماع البنك
الاسلامي للتنميه وزير الاقتصاد الايراني
والتقى مع الوزير الجدعان ووزير الماليه
السعودي وبالتالي يعني هناك خطوات عمليه
ندخل احنا ندخل الان بشكل عملي وبشكل اكثر
في المج الاقتصادي الاساسي والاتفاقات
الاقتصاديه وفود اقتصاديه من البلدين
اصبحت تذهب وتاتي هذا التسريع يعني
العلامات ودائما الاقتصاد هو المحكه
الاساسي للاتفاقات السياسيه
بما انه بدات عمليه تدفق للمشروعات حتى
المستوى النظري بسبب في فرق معين انه
ايران دوله مجهوله مغلقه يعني انت تستثمر
مثلا على سبيل في ماليزيا واضح المشاريع
اليوم ايران دوله مغلقه بسبب العقوبات
وبسبب سادات ومسببنا ايضا مرحله استكشاف
لكن وهي كبيره والتدخل بهذا المساله
الاخير ايضا بين وزيرين مع الامير فيصل
طال عمرك ايضا مؤشر مهم
مؤشر مهم اقتصادي وسياسي في التحول وحضور
المملكه ايضا له دلالات معينه قد تكون لها
نتائج مستقبليه فيها بس جاسم منذ الاتفاق
الذي وقع في العاشر من مارس الماضي في
بكين حتى اللحظه كيف يمكن ان ننظر
لخطوات تنفيذ هذا الات الوتيره هل هي اتت
بشكل متسق مع اهميه هذا
الاتفاقا بوتيره سريعه وهل نفذت بشكلها
الكامل حسب متابعتك ومطابعتك انا اتاكد
انه الخطوات اكثر والثقه بين الطرفين اعلى
والتواصل اكثر استمراريه واكثر تنوعا
وتحددا لم يعد مقتصرا على اللقاءات بين
وزيري الخارجيه والتفاهمات اصبح دخول في
خطوات وهذا مؤشر فعلا ايجابي لم يكن متوقع
حجم الشكوك المرتفع جدا تراجع بدرجه كبيره
تراجب التالي ايضا بالعكس ارتفعت التفاؤل
بالدخول في الخطوات التنفيذيه المختلفه
على المستوى واحنا جدا انعكاسات ترى
مختلفه انعكاسات هذه لنقل بهذا الاتفاق
السعودي الايراني تحديدا الامن بدرجه
كبيره في اغلاق الملف اليمني طبعا نسمع
على سبيل المثال الكلام من الايرانيين
اليوم يتحدثون عن فكره انشاء تكتل بحري
وفرقه بحريه امنيه هذه خطوه اذا تحققت
يعني ايضا السعوديه اطمئن تماما لمرسه
وانه تغير ايضا لكن خطوه طبعا من اجل تتم
تتطلب كثير من المعايير والاتفاقات
والتفاصيل الفنيه
هناك جانب مهم سعوديه دوله لا تتكلم كثيرا
يعني لو لو جمعنا في الفتره الماضيه من 10
مارسين اليوم لنا كاد نجد تصريحات سعوديه
كثيره عنا لكن نجد خطوات عمليه نجد تذهب
نجد لقاءات نجد اجراءات تنفذ نجد استجابات
معينه وبالتالي خطه عمل وليست هي المساله
يعني لم يكن توقع الاتفاق من الاساس
عاطفيا وبالتالي النتائج ليست عاطفيه
نتائج محسوبه وتقوم على المدى الهدف
الاساسي تحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه ان
نكون شركاء هل تحقق ذلك بمعنى
الملامح الاولى تقول يعني نسال هل هل هذا
الاتفاق وما جرى ايضا بعده من لقاءات ما
جرى ايضا بعده ربما من تصريحات من تقارب
اعاده السفراء ايضا كذلك او تسميه السفراء
القنصليات كيف انعكست على حاله السلم
والام الاقليميه اليوم حتى الان هل يمكن
ملاحظتها التغيير فيها كذلك طبعا بعض
التفاصيل تحتاج الى وقت لكن نعم يمكن
احفظها حاله الاستقرار في اليمن طبعا هذا
جانب اساسي العمل مشترك نحن نتكلم ايضا
على جوانب من المشكله ليست متصله بالاتفاق
بشكل مباشر لكن مثلا الميليشيات في العراق
في سوريا في بناء اعاده الوضع الاستقرار
في العالم العربي نجد انه مثلا العراقيين
عنه انهم يعني يعملون على ان يكون ممرات
للتجاره الانفتاح في الجرس هذه خطوات طبعا
لا تتم بسرعه لكن لنقل انه البصمات للتجري
او الاجراءات اللي يتم اتخاذها هناك لنقل
نوع من الشغف او الرغبه الكبيره في
الاستثمار المشترك ايران تدعو السعوديه
لبناء الفنادق تدعو الى المشاركه في الغاز
والنفط اليوم مثلا في الاستثمار فيها
تحاول ان تستفيد من المهارات والخبرات
السعوديه في هذا الجانب ان تتحول ايضا
البضائع الايرانيه هذه الاجراءات تمشي
وبالتالي هذا يرتد بشكل اساسي ولم يكن
بشكل اتفاق الطرفين المملكه وايران قوه
الكريان والجراين المهمين ايضا
والتقارب في المسار نحن نقول هناك شبكه
معقده من المصالح والارتباطات لا يمكن حتى
لا نكون مندفعين او عاطفيين لكن هي تحسب
بمعايير محدده وبالتالي كيف يمكن بشكل
اساسي ان نعمل سويا فيما يحقق مسرحتنا
مشتركه ويحقق الاستقرار اليوم هناك
عطفا على ما ذكرت سيد جاسر انه في اتجاه
الى التنميه اتجاه الى الاقتصاد يعني
بكافه اشكال التبادلات التجاريه وغيرها
وبان المنطقه اليوم اصبحت تعيش حاله ربما
تنمويه مزدهره اكثر بما يحقق هذا
المشروع السعودي تحديدا لولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان الذي ذكر في
اكثر من مره بان الشرق الاوسط سيتحول يوما
ما الى اوروبا جديده هل الظروف مواتيه
اليوم لهذا الامر ام لا نحتاج الى وقت
نحتاج الى بناء ثقه نحتاج الى تواصل اكثر
انا بقول بس مبادره الامير مبادره الشرق
الاوسط الاخضر الامير محمد بن سلمان هي
مبادره في شكل العام بي
في شكلها الظاهري او الخاتم لكن كيف ممكن
تكون تتحقق بهذا المساله اذا لم تكون هناك
تنميه وناقص استقرار وتحاون كيف يمكن فرد
هذه المظله الخضراء مثلا من لم يكن هناك
البلدان تعيش حاله من الرخاء والاستقرار
والعمل المشترك نعم هناك نجد اليوم مثلا
التحول مع سوريا ايجابي والعمل على عدد
سوريا واعاده تنميتها وادخلها في المجموعه
العربيه بشكل كامل والتخلص من الرواسب
والقضاء على الجماعات الارهابيه وركض نعم
نجد ان هناك فعلا ليست هناك مشروع قوي تم
العمل عليه
سنواجه مطبات محتمل بعض الصعوبات تتعلق في
نقاط لكن المظله الكبرى نعم ستستمر لانها
تقوم على معطيات واضحه ومحدده وتكون على
خطوات واجراءات وتعامل دقيق نحن لا نتفاهم
على المساله يعني من السهل البيانات لكن
من الصعب اتخاذ الاجراءات فاذا وصلنا كلما
تعمقنا في الجانب الاقتصادي دخلنا في
المرحله الاكيده والواثقه والمطمئنه لانه
هذه ارهانات برؤوس اموال هذه دهانات
استثماريه لا تغامر بشكل ايضا متهور ما لم
يكن هناك ضمانات ويقين اننا نسير في
المسار الصح اشكرك جزيل الشكر في
الاستوديو الكاتب الصحيحه في جاسر الجاسر
شكرا سيد جاسم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات